[Applaus]
[Musik]
der euro ist dass kinder der weltwährung
die der liegt ist ihn zu kritisieren
aber letzten endes stellt sich heraus
dass die leute von denen man dies nie
erwarten würde ihnen dann doch benutzen
sicher habt ihr schon von vielen
ökonomen und experten aller art allerlei
vorhersagen über das ende der
einheitlichen europäischen währung
[Musik]
das beste was deutschland für europa tun
kann wäre aus der gemeinsamen währung
auszutreten
aber das wird es nicht tut jerry elliott
im guardian
der euro ist eine offensichtlich
fehlerhafte konstruktion und seinen
architekten wussten dies zum zeitpunkt
seiner entstehung george vor
dennoch ist die realität eine ganz
andere tatsächlich bis der euro die arme
zweit häufigsten genutzte reservewährung
der welt und damit ende dieses videos
werdet ihr sehen dass er vielleicht gar
nicht so weit davon entfernt ist nummer
eins zu werden
dazu müsst ihr verstehen dass ein
drittel des globalen handels in euro als
geschäfts- büro- verwendet 20 prozent
der währungsreserven alle zentralbanken
lauten ebenso und viele andere länder
gäben ihre schuldverschreibung in dieser
werbung
aber das ist noch nicht alles wenn ihr
bracht jedem ressort politik schaut
wisst ihr bereits das dauert schon damit
angefangen hat verschiedene zölle im
internationalen handel zu erheben
und was bedeutet das denkt man
eigentlich kommt drüber nach wenn die
amerikaner weniger waren im ausland
kaufen werden dadurch weltweit weniger
dollars erlaubten und auch der anderen
seite ja er ist gerade dabei neue
freihandelsabkommen mit jedem
dahergekommen den streuner abzuschließen
genau die europäische sie hat ein
weitreichendes abkommen mit kanada
abgeschlossen das so genannte abkommen
aber das war nicht das einzige in den
letzten zwei jahren hat europa league
solle im handel mit japan mexiko und
vielen anderen sind mit anderen worten
je mehr die europäer im ausland
einkaufen desto mehr euros werden sie in
umlauf bringen dies bedeutet dass es in
zukunft einen moment geben könnte in
denen es statt einer dominierende
reservewährung zwei davon geben wird den
us dollar okay okay ich weiß was du
jetzt denkst was bringt uns das ganze
weit ist ist irgendwie nützlich für die
europäerin euro als hegemoniale währung
zu etablieren nun ja und gleichzeitig
nein wenn ihr dieses video und einem
regen anschaut und sagen wir mal eine
firma habt wird euch der euro als
weltreservewährung nicht allzu viel
helfen
aber wenn du für eine europäische
regierung aber das junge dann wirst du
glück 00 euro fernsehen
[Musik]
mit einer größeren nachfrage nach euro
bekommt die europäische zentralbank
einen größeren spielraum um geld zu
drucken ohne dass der euro dadurch aber
das ist eine thematik über die wir
ausführlich in unserem video über den
dollar gesprochen haben
wenn du es noch nicht gesehen hast
findest du den link dazu in der
beschreibung zu diesem video hier ist
auch die große frage warum ist der euro
beliebter als jede andere regierung zum
beispiel warum gerade der euro und nicht
der chinesische yuan warum sind so viele
ökonomen trotzdem so kritisch gegenüber
den bürgern
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten aber bevor wir dies tun
lässt uns wie immer einen blick zurück
in die geschichte
existenzielle krise in den 70er jahren
waren die europäischen länder glücklich
miteinander handel treiben zu können
obwohl es damals noch keine europäische
union gab gab es etwas ähnliches denen
ist so genannten gemeinsamen markt
dennoch gab es ein problem jedes land
hatte seine eigene nationale währung und
jede währung funktionierte auf eine
andere weise
so war beispielsweise die d-mark stark
und stabil aber die italienische lira
wertete jeden zweiten tag ab stellt euch
folge situation vor er arbeitet für eine
deutsche bank und verleiht eine million
italienische lira an ein italienisches
unternehmen in diesem moment sind eine
million lehrer 1010 abwehrt
bis es zur rückzahlung des kredits wurde
die lehrer extra abgewehrt selbst wenn
ihr also eine bildung die ihrer
zurückbekommt erhaltet ihr beim
umtauschen teuren landeswährung nur etwa
900 deutschland beschäftigt war okay
also um so etwas zu vermeiden setzen
sich die europäischen politiker an einen
runden tisch und da ja haben scheinbar
versucht ein ziemlich starkes stück hin
zu bekommen schließlich einigten sie
sich auf etwas was die schlange im
tunnel landen also die schlange sollte
eine metapher seien für die
währungsschwankungen weil sich währungen
eben ab und auf bewegen wie eine
schlange und wenn man nicht will dass
sich diese schlange wie verrückt auf und
ab schlängelt baut man ein tool um sie
herum und in diesem tunnel schwankt die
währungen da nicht mehr so stark nur
schaut mal meine lieben zuschauer das
sagen die siebziger jahre eine verrückte
zeit in der bob marley doch am leben war
und schlaghosen total im trend lagen
aber hat dieses abkommen mit der
schlange im tunnel funktioniert
natürlich nicht in den 80er jahren
bewegten sich die europäischen währungen
wie eine total bis doch eine schlange in
einem sehr breiten tunnel auch und
deshalb setzten sich jahrzehnte später
europäische politiker wieder an einen
runden tisch diesmal in der
niederländischen stadt maastricht
das war 1992 und dieses abkommen hat er
jetzt einen richtigen namen
sie nannten es den maastricht-vertrag
jetzt meinten sie es wirklich ernst und
sagten jetzt ist schluss mit dem herum
galba wir werden eine gemeinsame
regierung für alle schaffen keine
wechselkurse keine schwankungen oder
ähnlicher wunsch etwas was hast du
gesagt großbritannien du wirst nicht
mitmachen ok großbritannien du kannst
uns mit einem to install in deinem 17
uhr tee und einem fahren auf der
falschen straßenseite mal kreuzweise
und so begann ein dreistufiger prozess
zur schaffung einer einheitlichen
währung 1999 begannen alle eu börsen mit
der notierung in euro und etwas später
begannen auch die europäischen bürger
die neuen euro münzen und scheine im
alltag zu verwenden mittlerweile haben
wir uns alle an den euro wird wie an
jeder andere normale währung aber macht
euch keine illusionen
damals handelte es sich um ein
beispielloses finanzielles experiment
gigantischen ausmaßes und so kamen die
ersten kritiker zustande
europa führt uns eine situation vor
augen die für eine gemeinsame währung
ungünstig ist es besteht aus separaten
ländern die verschiedene sprachen
sprechen unterschiedliche bräuche haben
und bei denen die bürger eine weitaus
größere treue zu und verbundenheit mit
ihrem eigenen land empfinden als mit
einem gemeinsamen markt oder der idee
von europa milton friedman und jetzt
fragt ihr euch vielleicht welche
probleme gibt es denn mit einer
einheitlichen währung
das ist einfach wenn wir eine
einheitliche währung haben wird diese
deutsche bank über die wir bereits
gesprochen haben keine probleme haben
einem italienischen oder griechischen
unternehmen geld zu leihen
also was passiert dann null da ist halt
ein währungsrisiko mehr gibt allein
deutsche banken die viel geld haben es
an ärmere italienische griechische und
spanische unternehmen
und so begannen nach einführung des euro
die reichen länder in den armen ländern
plötzlich riesige summen zu investieren
als gäbe es kein morgen
und ja ich weiß dass du jetzt denkst
wo ist das problem um die probleme
zeigen sich in einer krise
[Musik]
banken müssen größere verluste bei
griechischen krediten hinnehmen sagt der
deutsche finanzminister
grundsätzlich sind die europäischen
volkswirtschaften ärmer und schwächer
wenn es zu einer krise kommt sind ihre
unternehmen die ersten die in konkurs
ging
und wenn unternehmen ihre schulden nicht
mehr zurückzahlen können können dadurch
auch die banken bankrottgehen
das nennen wir dann ansteckungsrisiko
dies erklärt warum wäre der finanzkrise
im jahr 2008 so viele politiker und
ökonomen vorgeschlagen haben den euro
aufzugeben
viele von ihnen sprachen über die
schaffung von zwei verschiedenen euros
einem für die reichen länder solide und
stabile einen anderen milliarden euro
der stark abgewertet werden könnte uns
denn noch existierte euro heute immer
eine ahnung warum das werden wir sehen
[Musik]
es lebe das chaos die kritiker haben mit
einer sache vollkommen recht die
europäische zentralbank auch bekannt als
ezb ist ein moderner turm von babel sie
funktioniert ähnlich wie die regierung
eines landes und der vorstand ist so
etwas wie die exekutive aber es gibt
auch eine legislative den sogenannten
ezb-rat in diesem sind die vertreter
aller länder der euro zone aus spanien
aus frankreich deutschland zu wenigen
und so weiter nun alle länder die den
euro als währung eingeführt haben sind
dort vertreten diese jungs und mädels
sind die wahren entscheidungsträger sie
entscheiden ob die zinsen gesenkt werden
oder mehr oder weniger geld gedruckt
wird
aber bevor sie dies tun müssen sie eine
einigung erzielen und hier beginnen die
probleme
die südeuropäischen länder wollen mehr
geld
aber ihre nördlichen nachbarn nicht da
sie sich nicht einigen können ist es
fast unmöglich einschneidende
entscheidungen zu treffen nun wo ist das
problem eine währung zu haben die nicht
abgewertet werden kann weil sich der
ezb-rat nicht darauf einigen kann
ist das nicht eher eine stärke wir haben
auch visuell politik oft darüber
gesprochen wie beste währung ist die
stärkste wenn sich der wert ihres geldes
nicht ändert dass die inflation niedrig
und ihr könnt einkaufen gehen oder das
geld eben sparen ohne die angst haben zu
müssen dass er geld an wert ein
hier könnten sich die unternehmen können
weil ihr wisst dass ihr langfristig
investieren aber jetzt stellt ihr euch
vielleicht die frage ist der euro
eigentlich stabil nun schau dir diese
tabelle an
hier kannst du einen vergleich zwischen
den geldmengen angeboten so genannten
zwei der ezb und der amerikanischen
federal circuit hast du sehen wie sie
hand in hand gehen im bilde als 20
jahren ist bei eur solide geworden
wieder amerikanischen dollar
richtig haben die europäer bereits
vergessen was inflation überhaupt ist
zum besseren verständnis die
amerikanische zentralbank hat zwei
hauptziele sowohl inflation als auch die
arbeitslosenquote in den niedrig zu
halten
die europäische zentralbank hingegen hat
man ein ziel in ihrer agenda die
währungsstabilität du bisher haben sie
dieses ziel recht gut erfüllt also wir
können sagen dass sowohl die stabilität
als auch die weltweite verfügbarkeit des
euro mit dem des us dollar vergleichbar
sind aber könnte er nicht doch noch
stabiler und noch weiter verbreitet sein
die antwort lautet ja
[Musik]
heute leben in der eurozone und 320
millionen menschen fast so viel wie in
den vereinigten staaten
aber obwohl die europäische wirtschaft
erweist amerikanische kann die eurozone
wachsen solange ihr neue länder
beitragen
in den letzten zehn jahren haben 69
länder den euro als währung eingeführt
und obwohl das politische klima einem
solchen vorhaben im moment wohl nicht
gerade wohlgesonnen ist könnten polen
und die skandinavischen länder
irgendwann doch damit anfangen den euro
einzuführen
das ist aber noch nicht das ende der
fahnenstange denn es gibt viele andere
währungen die an den euro gebunden sind
in einem anderen video haben wir über
die ehemaligen französischen kolonien in
afrika gesprochen
dort haben wir erklärt dass länder wie
die elfenbeinküste und der senegal eine
gemeinsame währung namens cf frauen
benutzen diese währung ist an den euro
gebunden
wir sprechen hier von mehr als 150
millionen menschen in ländern mit sehr
hohen wachstumsraten
die anderen worten bei so vielen
menschen die euros in ihrem täglichen
leben benutzen sind genug scheinen
umlauf damit unternehmen diese währung
ernst nehmen müssen um im geschäft zu
bleiben
aber okay jetzt denkst du vielleicht ja
mag viele leute benutzen euro ist aber
weißt du welche andere währung auch
viele nutzer hat der chinesische yuan
auch bekannt als er wird heutzutage
immer beliebter also warum sollten wir
euros und nicht renminbi servette
nun wir werden gleich sehen
[Musik]
der fehler des yuan
du hast recht china ist voller lesen und
diese chinesen benutzen johanns für ihre
täglichen transaktionen ich zieht auf
dem markt eine hohe nachfrage nach
dieser währung nach sich auf den ersten
blick sollte dies ausreichen damit der
yuan zu einer internationalen
reservewährung bertone
nun es gibt da ein problem
china setzt eine jährliche persönliche
obergrenze von 50.000 us dollar für
auszahlungen mit ausländischen
bankkarten
du hast richtig gehört china will nicht
dass du an das land verlassen deshalb
haben sie viele kapitalmarkt protokoll
eingeführt mit anderen worten yuan auf
den internationalen markt zu finden
das ist keine leichte aufgabe china will
nämlich vermeiden dass chinesische
geschäftsleute geld ausländern ausführen
und damit ihr reicht über den
machtbereich der regierung hinzu da hat
die chinesische zentralbank viele
einschränkungen verhängt und bei euch
vorstellen könnt ist es in einer
diktatur wie der chinesische schwer an
die unabhängigkeit ihrer zentralbank zum
glauben
mit anderen worten wenn das team bin es
nötig hätte könnte er den zentralbanken
wieder austauschen und ihn anweisen nach
belieben geld zu drucken du glaubst wir
das nicht aber glaubst du wirklich dass
ein politisches system keine
auswirkungen auf eine ernährung hat dann
solltest du dir mal unser video über die
türkei ansehen dort siehst du schwarz
auf weiß was passiert wenn
autoritarismus und wirtschaftskrise mal
aufeinander
in der zwischenzeit bist du an der reihe
glaubst du dass der euro genauso wichtig
wie haben kann wie der dollar oder sehen
wir bald vielleicht eine ganz neue krise
welche die europäische einheitswährung
zerstören wird informiert uns über eure
stichhaltigen einsichten im
kommentarbereich unter diesen wie und
vergesst bitte nicht dass wir jede woche
brandneue videos veröffentlichen also
klickt auf den abo button und auch auf
das glocken symbol damit immer neue
benachrichtigungen erhaltet wenn wie ein
neues video veröffentlicht
wenn ihr diese episode gefallen hat wie
gewohnt sein leid teilen sie mit ihren
freunden und immer sehen wir uns das
nächste mal
[Musik]